ça
bonjour et bienvenue sur le plateau de 9
7 4 tv pour une nouvelle émission de
vivre ensemble l'émission qui vous parle
des compétences du conseil départemental
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de l'
académie des dalons et pour ce faire
nous recevons sur ce plateau
freddy g / responsable du service
académie des dalons un service qui est
rattaché à la direction mobilité
coopération et jeunesse on reçoit
également eric romano qui est chargé de
mission à l'académie des dalons de la
plaine des cafres également un dalon
indal d'allonnes sûr avec nous
aujourd'hui alors et cédric bakhta or
qui nous vient de la plaine des cafres
et nathanaël denain qui nous vient du
bernica alors bonjour à tous alors
frédéric j'ai su pour commencer on va on
va vous demander l' académie des dalons
c'est quoi écoutez ce qui existe
maintenant depuis bientôt deux ans on
est de mai de cette année deux oncles
d'espèce il existe et l'objectif de
dépasser d'apporter une réponse au
phénomène d'exclusion des jeunes 18-25
ans donc et bien sûr après en intégrant
un parcours parcours 12 mois donc un
contrat d'engagement de 12 mois une
partie une phase de canard ou le jeune
d'un travail et si vous voulez tout ce
qui est à la remobilisation du jeune
parce que ce sont des jeunes qui sont en
quête de l'europe et donc il faut
travailler ça avec une équipe de
socioprofessionnels et ensuite
le jeune a à bord a enfin intégré à
intégrer une mission de service civique
de neuf fois donc à partir de ce moment
là là où il va travailler avec le chargé
de destination et les charger décernant
où il faudra définir effectivement son
projet projets d'avenir projet qui sera
déterminée en fonction des compétences
qui sont et va évaluer dans ces 3
pauline donc à ce jour nous avons depuis
l'ouverture du site de béni car nous
avons accueilli c'est comme cette jeune
donc c'est en 2014 donc 6e promotion des
garçons deux filles deux garçons donc
trois promotions 6-3 promotion de
garçons et l'ouverture en fin d'année
2014 du site de l'ardenne des caf avec
douze jeunes donc eu la possibilité
d'occuper tout jeune on va revenir sur
la première étape donc contre un
engagement une signature de contrats
dans la géo qui va déboucher sur la
partie interne à est ce qu'on peut
parler de cette partie interne à cela
pendant trois mois les jeunes ils
arrivent ils ont ils intègrent comme un
rythme de vie bien précis avec des codes
avec un blason d une tenue bien
spécifique c'est tout ça ça a pour but
de leur apporter quoi il faut souffler
sur cette période de trois mois si on va
retravailler avec les jeunes sur des la
façon de vivre façon de vivre en
communauté
donc avec
la mise en face du rituel notamment le
matin accueil de lever des drapeaux
ensuite le conseil des dalons en fin de
semaine donc la vie en communauté
donc très important nous allons
travailler sur sur le dépassement de soi
donc il s'agira de remobiliser les
jeunes sur ces trois premiers mois avec
des ateliers spécifiques
d'accompagnement
soit des sorties prévues aussi également
sorties sportives mais aussi des
ateliers de renforcement
d'accompagnement psychologique parce que
nous savons très bien que ces jeunes ont
besoin de se reconstruire et c'est cette
piste pendant cette période à que nous
avons nous allons évaluer on va définir
les compétences de chacun et chacune
pour pouvoir ensuite arriver à un projet
un projet qu'on verra un bottier sur la
deuxième phase les vestiaires cédric
j'avais un petit parcours un parcours un
peu un peu compliqué est ce que tu peux
d'abord nous expliquer un petit peu
comment comment tu as députés le ta vie
professionnelle après après l'école et
ensuite qu'est ce que ça t'apporte est
justement de passer par cette phase
d'internât au niveau de toi tu as été tu
fais partie de la première promotion de
l'académie des talons de la plaine des
cafres donc comment au début
comment on arrive à l'académie est un
petit peu de parcours avant d'arriver à
l'académie on va où vit mon brevet des
collèges
ensuite j'ai fait des envieuses ri j'ai
passé mon bpgp à est mauvais il fait un
mode d'accueil au lycée pontois un an
avant que j'ai fait un bac pro vente je
veux qu'un non mais ça parle ça m'a pas
intéressé et ge arrêté puis j'ai fait un
contrat d'un an et aussi avec une
association
j'ai vu deux formations agricoles
d'accord et après ça quand même où la
houle à travailler un petit peu mais
j'ai fait un contrat avec l'association
pendant un an
donc c'est à prayssac en fait nous la
retrouvons un petit peu en rupture ou
telle grande difficulté d'accord et
c'est à ce moment là que l'on a entendu
parler de la qualité de l'eau j'ai
entendu par l'académie dalons par un
spot tv et qu'on ne connaît pas ces
coiffes et de recherche internet
mario tama l'académie de dole et ça
s'est bien passé c'est à dire ça a été
un petit peu quoi toutes les étapes
avant d'arriver à l'internât de la
plaine et caves belle avait des
entretiens un entretien avec et le
personnel et puis le deuxième à côté m6
colom il a appris ou intègre dont quatre
au sol
connaissez vous êtes intégré donc cette
période d'internât l'a pourtant quoi ou
personnellement est ce que vous l'avez
besoin justement de retrouver un cadre
un peu plus plus stricte entre
guillemets industrie après la vie en
collectivité pas traduire la cohésion le
dépassement soit il a appris à me
connaître à nancy il a fait un gros
boulot là où quand même parce que j'ai à
travailler sur le connard ici t'es pas
comme ça nous a quand même voilà zola
prix vraiment possession du dusit là
c'était important aussi
et comment ça s'est passé avec les
dalons avec avec l'encadrement et tout
ça les autres ballons l'encadrement
au début il est vrai pas facile mais
après aux fuites j'étais gamin dans la
capitale au d'accord il a au bout des
trois mois où il avait vraiment
l'impression qu'on l'avait retrouvé
confiance en nous laver une avc ou de
projets ou là vers l'avant c'est avec
beaucoup de changements
comparé au début qu'on me dit viens
d'arriver tous fait pareil mais plus
confiance en ses dires on l'avait un peu
moins
plus à l'est les audois d'accord ça
c'est important pour ça devait avoir
cette assurance là et donc lutter avec
eric romano donc genre de chantier
d'insertion cause elle consiste en quoi
consiste un petit peu le travail avec
avec le ballon pendant cette période là
c'est vrai que pendant la période de
trois mois donc monsieur bakhta autant
qu est une personne donc qui était très
refermé sur lui même et cette période de
trois mois comme il le disait ça à lui a
permis en tout cas de s'ouvrir vers les
autres alors il a avait effectivement
donc une formation en horticulture
où il a pu
validez simplement un domaine de
compétence parmi les quatre domaines de
compétences qui étaient demandés et à
l'académie d'allant il a pu aussi mettre
son savoir faire à disposition des hôtes
des hauts talons
donc il ya aussi cette solidarité cette
entraide qui se passe au niveau de
l'académie déjà long sur cette période à
ternat il ya aussi donc des chantiers
d'insertion et ont pu faire des
chantiers d'insertion ou là on travaille
en petit comité et où on développe les
compétences de chacun on peut avoir
effectivement des talents qui ont des
compétences en anti culture d'oc dalons
qui ont des compétences dans l'animation
d'autres qui a plus de compétences dans
l'administratif
donc notre le travail en tout cas de
l'équipe très professionnel qui a au
niveau de deux académies
c'est de pousser dont développés
continuent en tout cas à développer les
compétences qu'ils ont on est beaucoup
plus on travaille sur sur un côté
pratique que théorique
donc on amène les dalons en fin de
compte à se responsabiliser à se prendre
en charge et à développer a continué en
tout cas développer les compétences
qu'ils ont et c'est vrai dans le cas de
la situation de monsieur gbagbo hors
dons qui parlait de formation anti
culture
il a pu effectivement présenté un projet
au niveau de l'académie dalons avec
l'ensemble des autres dalons où il ya eu
un atelier donc environnement
embellissement du site où ils ont fait
plusieurs jardins donc avec où ils ont
planté des plantes aromatiques de
plantes médicinales qu'un coin jardin
fleurs
pour embellir ce site qu'on venait juste
de prendre possession donc au niveau de
la plaine des caps qu'on est aussi
implanté donc le premier la première
promotion donc on est arrivé sur ce site
donc au mois d'octobre et ouverture de
l'académie sur un thème des cartes le
1er décembre deux justement avant de
poursuivre nous nous rendons la plaine
des cafres pour découvrir cette première
promotion de l'académie vidal jimmy est
aujourd'hui fière d'accueillir sa mère
brigitte et sa maman de coeur amélie à
l' académie des dalons de la plaine des
cafres après des mois et des mois de
recherche de formation et d'emploi
cette pause de trois mois à l'internât
de l'académie a permis à jimmy de se
recentrer sur l'essentiel et s'offrir un
nouveau départ nous soit pour les peurs
du vin bien développés doivent bientôt
battre avant plus tard la réussite de
jimmy est une fierté pour sa mère avec
laquelle il entretient un rapport très
tendres malgré le fait qu'il a surtout
vécu avec amélie en famille d'accueil
ça fait deux ans et j'ai me trouvais
rien il peut y postuler partout dans
tous les niveaux
rien donc là les l'académie des dames
ont cessé ouvert sur la paie des caf
donc j'ai mis à postuler donc là il est
super a ravi de son petit truc il est
très très très bien dans ce domaine là
et puis moi aussi en même temps je suis
ravie aussi de tout ce à quoi il ya
beaucoup de soutiens dans les dalons il
ya beaucoup de choses à connaître et
voilà pour les jeunes je trouve que
c'est super c'est donc la première
promotion qui aujourd'hui s'installe
pour la levée des drapeaux
vous avez les couleurs
douze jeunes dont qui partent en
contrats de service civique et qui à
travers des associations des entreprises
participeront à la lutte contre
l'exclusion sociale tout en faisant la
promotion de la solidarité et à prier
après le bac pro ben may pu trouver ma
pas tout le travail dans ces domaines en
fin de compte trois mois l'a si bien se
passer
franchement si l expérience très
intéressant
là dans les trois mois là où apprendre
la cohésion l'entr'aide le surpassement
de soi et chez tout le travail d'équipé
ah oui gras grâce à ça dans ma confiance
en moi
la n1 - surtout à découvrir de nouvelles
compétences comme aux joies du bain la
de compétences dans l'animation des
jeunes qui ont activement participé à
l'embellissement de leur lieu de vie en
créant des espaces sur le terrain qui
les accueillent un potager des fleurs
ont été plantées
les travaux ont concerné l'habitation
principale avec diverses réparations
une promotion de garçons qui laisse
place à une promotion de jeunes filles
dans les hauteurs de la plaine des
cafres entre les montagnes et dans une
nature magnifique l' académie des dalons
tient toutes ses promesses celle de
rendre nos jeunes plus heureux donc
forcément plus fort pour atteindre les
rêves qu'ils se sont fixés comme on l'a
vu dans le reportage donc cette partie
internat c'est l'occasion aussi de
mettre en commun des projets entre les
jeunes de l'académie des dalons et le
les gens du quartier
cet immense semaine et à l'invitation
des jeunes étaient très fortes notamment
avec la population il a fallu à faire un
gros travail d'explication
notamment avec les gens du quartier
ça fait toujours été facile mais en tous
cas ont mis en relation en lien avec la
qu'il ya vous alliez en interne nous
avons pu développer en tout cas
valoriser les sites du du quartier et
avec en collaboration notamment des
habitants donc forte collaboration ce
niveau-là a été valorisé notamment le
site de notre dame de fatima où là tout
le monde a bien adhéré au projet et avec
au final une inauguration du site en
présence de toute la population des
jeunes et des parents aussi qui ont été
invités ce joueur donc
oui effectivement c'est c'est une
réussite à ce niveau là une partie
interne très riche
et puis après mon passé les trois mois
ça se termine et là on passe à la paire
partie du service civil alors la la
qu'est ce qui se passe pour le servette
comme jeu c'est alors à la fin des trois
mois donc dans un mois nous avons éteint
depuis identifier les compétences
de chaque jeune et par rapport à leurs
potentialités et à par rapport à ceux
tout cela nous nous construisons nous
mettons en place des missions de service
il donc dans le champ de compétence
notamment du conseil général mais aussi
en relation un lien avec des
associations partenaires
le réseau des réseaux associatifs du
conseil général dont nos jeunes ensuite
qui part donc pour ans avait aussi fait
pour une série de neuf mois 9 mois et de
quatre maternelles qui se trouve à la
bibliothèque départementale actuellement
bonjour la cannelle en revanche beaucoup
en fait toi est ce que tu peux revenir
un petit peu sur sur ton parcours et
puis après nous dira un petit peu qu'est
ce qui se passe depuis que tu es tu as a
service civique qu'est-ce que ça
t'apporte l académie des dalons ça
m'apporte une deuxième chance il
aujourd'hui sur mission de république
oui civique à la bibliothèque
dépendantes à l'académie dalons nous
avons donc de deux chars jeune
association donc insurgés station sur le
bianic anja chargée d'insertion à
syndicats
nous avons également un chat un chat
rejet d'externat donc ses charges et des
sessions avec le charger d'externat
travaillent en collaboration ensemble
dans le but d'accompagner nous soutenir
le jeune dans son projet avant de
terminer on va écouter chez jal d'amour
le directeur de la direction mobilité
coopération et jeunesse qui va nous
expliquer comment pouvoir intégrer une
promotion de l'académie d'été
c'est concerne les jeunes de la réunion
de 18 à 25 ans essentiellement inscrits
au pôle emploi ou à la mission locale
répandent en répondant également à des
critères de motivation c'est l'élément
essentiel qu'il aurait demandé une
grosse motivation ils vont passer un
surnombre d'entretien l'entretien
motivationnel suivie d'une décision d'un
jury et derrière il y aura un entretien
dans le meilleur des cas avec une
psychologue à l'issue duquel il ya
l'admission et ils intégreront ainsi
l'académie des vallons alors laquelle
vidalon on vous l'a dit on l'a redit
c'est sur une période de trois mois
d'internât et de neuf mois terminées vic
donc il faut aussi bien évidemment que
ces jeunes aient répondu à la journée
d'appel national qu'ils étaient au moins
recensés c'est l'essentiel
mais une grosse motivation pour est
fondamental pour pouvoir intégrer cette
cette académie et devenir des académies
fait un x termine cette émission merci à
tous et rendez vous pour une prochaine
mission vivre ensemble sur l'antenne de
noces à capter et à bientôt